that was right
where's all the goodies right jaffa
cakes happily hurry pack something this
is a great thing for diet listen whose
idea was this
probably the twin cakes got these [ __ ]
out of here now for the lava
what's this
okay go this smell terrible but I go for
the blue Stilton for sure that was
running boom so we've got freezing cold
Gregg sausage road
no that tastes like Vienna McDonald's
sausage your head come off in this winds
up Donald's all the way baby
I am breathe I know I am very taste like
what's this this is the root beer boy
[Applause]
there's a bit like toothpaste
I do like not those which is not really
fair I like them both I'm gonna call it
a draw
gentleman's relish I'll say this before
looks like a hair gel dummy delicious on
the hot toast City we've got hot toast
that was wrong fish guts or something
yeah
the fourth wins
30 times out of a million you know once
we got where's all the goodies
oh yeah cioppino pepper
not familiar poor sucker I know what
these taste like yeah they're not my
favorite but they are good good
inspection uh I'm in a problem in a few
minutes how am I gonna drop my share is
full after all that [ __ ] so here we
are I'm gonna drop this book book line
yeah after all that complete shite ya
got Barbie book check it out really
serious help you in your life if you
don't like on buy some squat eating
[Laughter]
[Music]